at this altitude i can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands start to
shake
can i answer your personal question
[Music]
i'm a cybernetic organism living tissue
over metal
[Music]
this episode is brought to you by
expressvpn i've been using expressvpn
since last summer
and i started using it as a full retail
paying customer i always test things
before
considering sponsors and i find it to be
a super reliable way to make sure that
my data
are secure and encrypted you like how i
said data are like a pompous ass
but i like to ensure that my data are
secure and encrypted
but to do so without slowing down my
internet speed
if you ever use public wi-fi at say a
hotel or coffee shop where i often work
and as many of my listeners do you're
often sending data over an open network
meaning no encryption whatsoever one way
to ensure
that all of your data are encrypted and
cannot be easily read by
hackers or script kits or whoever is by
using expressvpn and the onboarding
process for expressvpn
meaning the signup flow the use of the
product is one of the best i've ever
seen in my life
all you need to do is download the
expressvpn app on your computer
or smartphone and then use the internet
just as you normally would
you click one button in the expressvpn
app to secure 100 of your network
data it's kind of ridiculously simple
and as many of you know i only recommend
brands that i have researched
and vetted thoroughly for me of the many
vpn solutions out there expressvpn is
one of the best on the market and i use
it personally
here a few reasons why first privacy
expressvpn
does not log your data lots of cheap or
free vpns make money by selling your
data believe it or not
to ad companies and so on expressvpn
developed a technology called trusted
server to prevent
their servers from logging your
information second
speed many vpns slow your connection
down or make your device
seem sluggish just to a crawl i've been
using expressvpn
for a while now as i mentioned and my
internet speeds are blazingly fast i
don't even notice it honestly i forget
that it's even on
so that includes when i connect to
servers thousands of miles away or
during travel i can still stream hd
quality videos with zero lag
the last thing that really sets
expressvpn apart is how easy it is to
use
as i mentioned earlier unlike other vpns
you don't have to input or program
anything
you just start up the app click one
button and that's it
super super simple and by the way it's
not just me saying all this about but
expressvpn
you've got techradar the verge cnet and
many other
publications rating expressvpn as the
number one vpn
in zeverd so consider protecting
yourself
with the vpn that i use and trust use my
link expressvpn.com
tim today and get an extra three months
free on a one year package
that's expressvpn.com
tim visit expressvpn.com tim
to learn more
this episode of the tim ferriss show is
brought to you by athletic greens
i get asked all the time if i could only
take one supplement
what would it be the answer is
inevitably athletic
greens i view it as and a lot of you now
view it as
all-in-one nutritional insurance i
recommended it way back in 2010 in the
four-hour body
and i did not get paid to do so i've
been using it since before that
and i use it in a lot of different ways
i travel with it to avoid getting sick
or to help mitigate the likelihood of
getting sick i take it in the morning to
ensure optimal performance and overall
it covers my bases if i can't get what i
need from whole food meals
throughout the rest of the day and if
you want to give athletic greens a try
they're offering a free 20 count travel
pack
for first time users i nearly always
travel with at least
three or four of these one dose bags in
other words if you buy athletic greens
as a first time buyer
you now get for a limited time an extra
79 dollars in free product
so check out the details at
athleticgreens.com forward slash
tim again that's athleticgreens.com
forward slash tim
for your free travel pack with any
purchase
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is tim ferriss welcome to another
episode of the tim ferriss show where it
is my job
as always to deconstruct world-class
performers
to tease out that habits routines
influences favorite books and so on
that you can apply to your own life my
guest today
is a friend maurice ashley
maurice ashley is an incredibly
impressive
human being on so many levels and we get
to really dig into
a number of facets of his life story and
lessons learned
maurice ashley is the first
african-american international grand
master in the annals of the game of
chess
and he has translated his love to others
as a three-time national championship
coach
published author espn commentator iphone
app designer puzzle inventor and
motivational speaker
in recognition for his immense
contribution to the game maurice was
inducted into the us chess
hall of fame in 2016. his book chess
for success subtitled using an old game
to build new strengths in children and
teens
shows the many benefits of chess
particularly for at-risk youth
his tedx talk working backward to solve
problems
has more than a million views he's also
appeared with me in the brazilian jiu
jitsu episode which has some chess
of the tim ferriss experiment tv series
way back in the day
joined by our mutual friend josh
waitzkin maurice is
very well known for providing dynamic
live tournament coverage of world-class
chess competitions and matches his high
energy
unapologetic and irreverent commentary
combines brooklyn street smarts
which we talk about quite a bit with a
professional espn style sports analysis
he's covered every class of a lead event
including the world chess championships
the u.s chess championships the grand
chess tour and the legendary man versus
machine matches between gary kasparov
or is it kasparov i never get that right
and ibm's
deep blue traveling the world as a
spokesperson for the many character
building effects of chess
maurice consults with universities
schools chess clubs executive and
celebrities on how
chess principles and strategies can be
applied to improve business practices
and accelerate personal
growth you can find him online maurice
ashley dot com
on twitter at maurice ashley and on
facebook
grandmastermauricea and on instagram
maurice ashley
chess without further ado please enjoy
this wide-ranging conversation with
none other than maurice ashley
maurice welcome to the show thanks for
having me
i've been looking forward to this and
hoping to have you on the show for so
many years now
and we've had many different points of
connection but
of course it began with our mutual
friend
and also popular podcast guest josh
waitzkin
who has known you for a very long time
indeed and he has a quote
in fact that is in praise of your book
chess for success and it goes as follows
quote maurice ashley has been
like a brother to me since i was 12
years old i know the man i know the
competitor i know the artist and i know
the teacher
there's a lot of terrain for us to cover
a lot of nooks and crannies to explore
but i thought we would begin
with maurice the jamaican and
i was hoping you could describe for us
your beginnings
and we could start with the with the
genesis well
yes i was born in jamaica the island
not the area of queens and
i grew up there i was there until i was
12 years old before i came to this
country
but probably the most significant thing
that happened for me in jamaica was the
fact that my mother
left jamaica to come to the united
states when i was two years old my
brother was ten
my sister was seven months old and
she had this opportunity to come to the
u.s but she couldn't bring all of us at
the same time she'd
only bring herself and her leaving was
really quite an event in our lives
my father wasn't with us uh living with
us at the time
so we grew up with our grandmother and
my mother would send
down stuff supplies to jamaica whether
it be
food stuffs flour and rice she sent him
in a barrel and she said
books she'd send like notebooks and she
i remember sending
like a softball and a glove and of
course in jamaica nobody played softball
baseball nothing
so i threw the glove to the side not
knowing what to do with it
and we used the softball as a soccer
ball
it got pretty worn down pretty quickly
it really turned into a softball very
quickly after that um
but we just being raised by my
grandmother she was a teacher by
training uh and so she would
teach us so much as
as young people so we were really well
prepared
educationally because of my grandmother
and she was 64 years old at the time my
mother left she had imagined
a 64 year old having had seven children
of her own
now suddenly taking on the care of her
daughter's children
at that age you know when you might be
thinking about maybe
slowing down and retiring enjoying
yourself but for the next 10 years she
took care of us
and that was really a hugely significant
part of
growing up living there until finally my
mother got the resources and the
paperwork through to get us green cards
and finally bring us to the united
states
when or how does competitive drive
enter the picture i love doing
homework on friends of mine before they
come on the show because i always find
these things that i've never known
such as some of the athletic
accomplishments
of your siblings could you describe
your siblings a bit and then speak to
the competitive aspect
well yes we are a competitive family my
older brother devon
is a kickboxer boxing trainer now but he
was a three-time
world champion kickboxer and my sister
the baby alicia
was a six-time world champion boxer
and so we always joke about who's better
and who's got more accolades and
we always try to one-up each other and
you know one gets into the hall of fame
the others are upset and the other one
gets in the hall of fame and like my
sister's not in the boxing hall of fame
yet so we're
she's like oh man you guys got that on
me so
yeah we we definitely are a very
competitive family it started
i think it's it started very young i
mean my mother despite not being a
competitor herself had a tremendous
drive our family had a drive
to succeed you know our circumstances
were extremely modest jamaica wasn't
what people think of it as that at least
the northwest side of jamaica's
montego bay and ocho rios and nick grill
and you know any party and all that
reggae sons flash but we lived in
kingston uh
and kingston was people packed on top of
each other
uh in not great conditions and so
we knew we wanted to be something
special but you just wanted to have the
resources to be able to do that and
i think it was really fortunate that we
finally got that opportunity in my
mother's
diligence and eventually my father
re-entered our lives as well and he
he's a dancer he's a dance teacher he
was a professional dancer
danced with martha graham and uh was
very accomplished at his own dance
company as well
so you know the family was just a pretty
driven bunch
why did it come to pass that you moved
to the u.s at 12
how did that happen and why did that
move happen again my mother she wanted
to bring us up but she couldn't
by the rules at the time just bring her
family with her so she was allowed
in the 60s there was a mass immigration
of caribbean folks
but you had to come by yourself in the
main
and then after you had proven yourself
on your own citizenship papers
etc you were able to bring your family
up
and so a lot of children they were
called barrel children
which meant that parents would come
usually by themselves
to the country and then they would send
down supplies
in a barrel so you'd wait for that
barrel to be shipped
so you could open it up and get all the
goodies
from uh from your parent and
that barrel was an indicator of how much
my mother was working in order to supply
the materials for us to be able to
survive in jamaica
and it took her 10 years and that's what
happened just took her 10 years she was
in new york
the whole time she's at first she was a
nanny
then she got an office job and saved up
her money and got herself ready because
her three children were going to be with
her
and she wanted to be able to afford that
and take care of us and so
in 1978 we finally were able to come up
and it was it was just like
her dream basically come true a dream
come true for
us as well because we had been living
without our mother for 10 years
and you can imagine when that finally
came to pass it was just it was just
like a fairy tale
was it also strange to be reunited after
all that time
absolutely or was it no absolutely
bizarre i mean my
first our grandmother was really our
mother especially for me
and my sister right because we were so
young
i was two my sister was less than a year
old
and so we we didn't have intimate
knowledge of this woman
she would visit us when she could every
year if she could but
sometimes it took longer and
we would write her letters it's funny
she showed us the letter she saved the
letters we wrote her
from over 40 years ago and i didn't know
she had them
until last summer and she took out
this pile of letters these are the
letters actually it's my daughter who
went down to interview her my daughter's
a budding filmmaker
the interviewer my daughter said do you
know that grandma has letters that you
wrote
her from 40 years ago it's like what are
you talking about she says yeah she's
been saving them all the time
so when i finally go down and visit her
again i see these extraordinary letters
that we wrote to her that kept that
connection and you
imagine it's not email this is letters
handwritten letters
being sent and waiting an expectation
for letters to come back
for our mother to tell us about how life
was where she was and
and uh for her to hear from us and
i was a pretty poetic kid i told her
you know wrote poems to her how much i
loved her and how i missed her and all
that
you know it was quite an extraordinary
thing to do
to be able to go back and see myself as
a six-year-old seven-year-old
eight-year-old
you know as my thoughts evolved and my
intellect grew
uh as i wrote her letters so it was
it really was an extraordinary thing
very strange to finally meet this
mythical figure
would sacrifice so much for us to have a
better life
where did you land in the u.s
and how did chess enter the picture
we ended up in brownsville brooklyn
brownsville
is the same neighborhood that mike tyson
grew up in
and i often make the joke that
brownsville was so rough
that mike had to get out of brownsville
and it was that tough i mean
my mother was able to get us this
apartment that she could afford which
was a two bedroom
apartment there were four of us so my
brother sister
and i were in the one room one bedroom
the bunk bed and
the roll out bit actually and my mother
had the other bedroom
and my brother at the time was 20 years
old so
you can imagine a 20 year old having to
sleep in the same room as his
younger brother and sister but you know
he got his life together
pretty quickly went to school and got
work
and then moved out but that's what she
could afford
and it was just you know what it was and
the brownsville
in the late 70s early 80s was what you
can imagine what brooklyn was
not not today's brooklyn you know you've
got starbucks and lattes and
and park slow moms you know that's
forget it
this was this was bk this was hardcore
this was drug dealers shooting every
single night
not necessarily at anyone but just to
remind the neighborhood who was in
charge
there were prostitutes on the corners
uh you had car thieves i mean it was
it was a hot mess it was brooklyn urban
blight is
at its worst new york has changed a lot
since brooklyn especially has changed a
lot since then but then back then
it was really tough and to answer the
second part of your question sorry
and chess came into my life when i went
to brooklyn technical high school now i
knew the rules of chess actually
i knew the rules of chess from jamaica
because we played a lot of games in
jamaica
we didn't have television tv came on at
six o'clock at night
and the first thing that came on was the
news and it was two channels
so who you didn't want to watch that as
a kid
so you learned to play games and i had a
very passionate love of games and it was
a lot of board games whether it was
checkers which we call drafts whether it
was
card games and chess was one of those
games
that my brother and his friends got
hooked into and i
kind of played around with it for a bit
my brother said i used to be in the
backyard
just moving the pieces around by myself
i don't even recall doing that but
later i came when i came to the us
uh in high school i saw a friend playing
and that's when i got involved i started
playing
this guy i thought i could beat and it
just crushed me and i couldn't
understand it and you know again
competitive side
it's like what's going on and it just so
happened i was in this in the library
that i saw a book on chess and that's
where the love affair began
what was it about the book i if my
research is serving me right this is a
book i believe by paul morphy if i'm
getting the name correct
maybe maybe not but what was it about
the book on chess and your experience
that
gripped you so much it wasn't by paul
morphy
it included paul morphy as one of the
greatest chess players of all time
and i don't know if it was solely the
book or the fact that i wanted to
kick my friend's ass like
like wait a minute there's a book oh i'm
going to take this out his name was
kloter kolas
his family is from haiti another
immigrant family and
but everybody called him chico and chico
just had mauled me and it's like this
and then there was a book
wait a minute i'm taking out this book
i'm going to study the book
and then i got something for chico and i
read it i was fascinated wow there's
strategies
you're supposed to do certain specific
openings and
these ideas i didn't know any of it
existed
and then i so when i was done i went
back to play him
and the first game i played him crushed
me again and it turns out
that he had read that book and many
other books
and he he had game and i was stupid
thinking that i was going to get him but
then
that really stoked the fire and from
then on we played chess
every single day after school like every
single day
it was basically school homework chest
and that was my life in high school so
never underestimate
the the hellfire fueled redemption from
an
ass kicking i think would be one moral
to take away from that
and the next chapters that followed i've
done a little bit of reading
and i suppose we could start with the
black bear school of
chess what is the black bear school of
chess
that is indeed the next chapter the
group itself black bear school was a
group of
largely african american males one
latino
brother in there as well
they were a group who played chess
together either in the parks or at each
other's homes
they took chess deathly seriously
uh they studied books they studied
encyclopedias
they studied chess material magazines in
other languages
even if they didn't speak them they
would get out
of dictionary from a magazine i remember
uh
you have a german magazine or a russian
magazine
chocolaty bulletin and they would take a
dictionary
and go over each word translating word
by word to find out what was in
the material which you know you think
about i mean there's no google translate
right
you're literally you don't speak the
language you're literally trying to
figure out
word by word what the explanation is uh
of course the piece names were different
but they were consistent so
for example in russian a bishop is a
sloan and
it would look like a capital letter c so
whenever you saw that you knew
that was the name of the piece that was
moving and then you know what square was
moving to
so at least the games they could go over
very easily
but the explanations they had to look up
and do it very slowly
so you can imagine the seriousness they
took chess with and i got to meet them
when a friend of mine who i was beating
told me that he knew a group
that could beat me and i was a big trash
talker so when he said that i was like
please
bring it and he told me about the black
bear school and he took me
to one of their homes uh the home of
willie johnson who remains
a mentor to me today everybody calls him
pop but he's just like
he was like a father figure to me and i
went and i played willie that first game
and he was just so friendly and amicable
and he thought he was going to teach me
a lesson
then it turns out that i was good enough
to hang with him
and that's that was my indoctrination
into this group
that just was so amazingly competitive
you cannot imagine i mean we were
already competitive and these guys
were out to kill each other every single
day every single time they played they'd
play
on the weekends they would stay at
willy's house from
friday night until sunday and just be
playing chess
and generally speaking we're talking
about blitz chess not the slower
classical version where
you stop and think for a while but the
fast version we're just like dynamic and
the clock as you know uh so
it was just fun to to be in that kind of
group and they didn't teach me anything
when they i was the youngest one i was a
big trash talker
they were very upset when i talked so
much trash you gotta respect your elders
they were generally about seven to
fifteen years older than me
but they knew i had competitive fire and
so
their way of teaching me was to beat me
down
send me home and make me go study and
that was
training by fire you see just to define
some terms you mentioned
classical chess and blitz chess the the
way i've heard
you describe the difference and i want
you to fact check this and correct me if
i get anything wrong but in classical
chess you might have a
four hour session say back in the day
four hour session
a break you sort of recuse yourselves
study the position come back the next
day play another four hours you can take
your time
with blitz chess how much time does each
side have
or i guess it varies but the way that
you guys played
yeah five minutes per side for the whole
game
it's a two-faced clock so each side has
their own time whenever i make a move i
press the clock
and the other person's time starts
ticking my time freezes and we play the
game that way if you run out of time you
lose so you can imagine five minutes
total per game that you have
even faster than blitz you have bullet
which is one minute per side which
which is really like edward scissorhand
speed pieces are moving
but five minutes was still plenty fast
but enough time for you to study the
position somewhat get a good feel
and go a lot more instinct a lot more
tactical tricks and traps
some definitely room for strategic play
but classical chess
back in the day as you described it you
would adjourn games after the first
time period when computers came along
you couldn't adjourn games anymore
because people could just go to the
computer and ask for help
so that killed the germans and now games
could last between
three and a half to six hours there's no
set time because you keep getting time
added
depending on the number of moves you
play and it varies but like i said
between three and a half to six hours
that gives you ample time to study to be
accurate to analyze all the moves
to play strategic niceties nuances
but that's not what we grew up with in
brooklyn it was it was all body blows
just hit him hit him again hit him again
what
i mean and guys had tactics when i say
tactics
i mean moves that were like pyrotechnics
you know you you think where did that
come from you thought you had the
position under control and
and somebody would drop a move and it
would just explode on the board it's
like
what that's playable like so you you
just had to be absolutely
fierce and focused and maintain that
discipline
all the way through because these guys
were were true ninjas
on the board so let's talk about focus
and maybe a um like a caltrop
under the foot of focus smack talking
right so trash talking
is an art form and there are different
schools in this this art different
approaches
could you describe some of the the
different schools
of trash talk or different approaches to
trash talking because this is something
i had very little exposure to but
i'll give people a preview we'll
probably talk about this a little bit
later but you and i
spent some time together for the tim
ferriss experiment this tv series that
was done a handful of years ago
and we got this one clip of you playing
this
this trash talking uh player in a park
in new york city
that went completely viral has close to
seven million views now it's just
amazing and you you do see
how it's used to knock people off
balance
right so could you speak to just trash
talking
in general any way you want to tackle it
i think the most critical thing about
trash talking
is that it actually is very much
an individual thing right
it's more who you are than
what you're trying to do so
each person approaches it their own way
based on their personality
and if you're low key your trash talking
is going to be understated you're not
going to be loud and braggadocious
like all in the guy's face because
that's not who you are so you would
throw your own self off
if you did that you insult the person or
get inside their head the way
you would as yourself and so you have
the people who
will just be real star low key sarcasm
right uh it won't even necessarily be
fancy
you know they might say something like
really that's what you're gonna play i
mean it's you know there's
nothing there's nothing big nothing
fancy uh but
it'll be in your brain somewhere it'll
plant that earworm right and then
they'll start
over and over somebody like ralph's
mouth
who would always say no matter what the
situation
that's what she said just
every single time that's what she said
you know um
i'm whipping your ass that's what she
said like
whatever whatever it was that was always
his line
uh then you had guys who would quote
shakespeare like vinnie livermore
who was played by lawrence fishburne in
josh wadeskin's
the movie about josh wadeskin searching
for bobby fischer
and vinnie he'd be quoting shakespeare
the whole time
he's like yeah you know you got to know
shakespeare to quote shakespeare
and clearly this guy knew shakespeare so
that was
another way or there'll be people who
stayed
very very let's call it
sexual in the conversation like graphic
and that was that really would throw you
off because chess pieces
would morph into sort of like you know
sex
toys uh in the description like
what like how did that come in your head
dude like could you please just play
chess
but that's where the conversation would
go and
and uh and anything they were doing you
know like the rook is penetrating into
the rear you know like what of your
position really okay
i'm gonna go with that so everything and
anything you come into depending on who
it was that you were talking to and also
of course
you you also have colorful language
right and
you couldn't avoid that either so yeah
trash talking
really i would say it's not so much in a
generic art form with
various schools and so much more so
the person expressing themselves at the
board in a way
that allows for them to feel like
they're in flow
and potentially disturbs your equanimity
and if that happens then you're done
like i saw people who were better chess
players
just lose their cool at the board
because the other guy just kept talking
and the worst thing to do
to a trash talker is tell them to stop
talking that's the first time
now you're done you're like really okay
i'm gonna stop talking
you know i'll stop talking because i
want to respect you so i'm gonna stop
talking right now
i mean really you're a better player so
let me stop
saying anything and disrespecting you by
talking that's what's gonna happen this
is gonna be unending stream
and you're never gonna get past it so
the best thing to do is to keep cool and
so for me that was real really good
training uh
in not being distracted no matter what
was happening around you
did any of those players in the black
bear school of chess black bear school
go on to play elsewhere uh and where did
you go
in terms of evolution from that point
absolutely these players ended up
becoming master players
like legit chess masters not as far as
grand masters and international masters
which is the highest levels of chess
grandmaster being the highest higher you
could have
but these were strong players
now the problem for the black bear
school
my opinion as i was coming up was i
recognized that
it was a bit too much infighting players
wanted to beat each other
so you had the best players like william
morrison
who we called the exterminator
or george golden the fire breather
um and then you had guys like ronald
simpson uh
as i mentioned willie johnson ernest
colding
mark mears chris welcome these guys were
serious high level talents
but their best wish was to
destroy each other that day and for me
coming up as a as a young player i was
in my teens
i didn't see the value in just beating
them because the people i was reading
about in the books
were grand masters famous players and i
wanted to be like the people in the
books
i wanted to play at that level and the
only way you could do that was if i
left the group or didn't stay just
inside the group
and played in the clubs in new york and
i was very fortunate because new york is
a hotbed for chess activity
and some of the strongest players in the
country were living in new york so
i started going to the manhattan club
the marshall chess club
those are the two venerable clubs and
playing against the grand masters there
and that took my game to another level
and it eventually allowed me in fact to
come back to the black bear school
and become the president as we called it
uh i
i started dominating those guys because
i wasn't just about playing
inside this one room did you decide to
go to the clubs did someone else suggest
it
no i did i did once i found out that
clubs were
there i wanted to find out who you know
who played there where
can you find the best players and so i
went
ah a friend of mine sam singh and i we
hung out he had a
hit a beat up car but it was good enough
and we would drive to the city
regularly and play tournament chess play
against
all the masters and international
masters and grandmasters of the club
and that's that really took our game to
another level what is the atmosphere
in the a venerable
chess club what does that look like what
does it feel like look as you would
expect
it was not brooklyn i could tell you
that not brownsville
it was different it was definitely
different you know you had people who
were coming out of work businessmen in
suits
they didn't quite know what to do with a
young
black kid from brooklyn and so
it was it was definitely a different
vibe
to what i was normally experiencing but
chess is chess
and once you see good moves you
understand you're playing against a
player
so i wanted to be that player whenever i
played against those guys and
you know that's what it was like so it
was it was definitely a much more formal
affair but it was
as long as it was about chess then i
didn't care
i want you to correct me if i'm getting
this wrong but i i read about a moment
when
things seem to have crystallized for you
in a way and that was watching tiger
woods in 1997.
was that an important moment for you
absolutely absolutely you're fast
forwarding big time though so now i'm
way out of my teens
i'm now uh at that time i'm 31 years old
so we're
jumping fast i had gone through many
experiences before then
but i had my quest to become a
grandmaster was
seemingly stymied because by then i had
a daughter
i to work for a living i was teaching
chess actually primarily but i was also
doing chess commentary
and the like and so i was fully involved
in
in sort of fatherhood and and making
money
and my dream was to become a grandmaster
so by the time we get to
the tiger in 1970 he was at the masters
and he dominated that masters you know
remember that was his coming out part
and that really struck a chord for me
because when i watched him
be a a dominant player in a sport that
largely didn't look like him and i was
in the same boat in my sport chess is a
sport yes
and i felt like one day i wanted to do
that i've been dreaming about that for
so long
and i had never done it so when i saw
tiger do that i went into a bit of a
depression
at first i was like what the heck you
know i'm distracted by all these things
that i'm doing and i'm not focusing on
my game my craft
my passion to finally do what i've
always wanted to do
and that eventually turned into
inspiration and search
the quest to finally do it and i was
very fortunate because at the time i was
working in an organization
a harlem educational activities fund
that had a sponsor by the name of dan
rose
he was the philanthropist who actually
who gave to this fund to help
young kids in harlem and i was teaching
in his chess programs and
would produce national champions and the
like
and he heard about
my dream and he said listen i'll support
you on this quest as long as you come
back to harlem after you're done and
give back
which i was very happy for that deal and
i was able to stop everything i was
doing and just focus on chess
and about 19 months later i got my final
norm that made me a grandmaster so i
want to dig into a bunch
of aspects of this because this seems
like it could be fertile ground for
exploring quite a bit when did the
depression get transmuted into
inspiration like how long did that take
what did it look like because a lot of
people and i've certainly had these
periods where
i i go into a low and i might recover
the baseline but it doesn't get
translated into this new
source of momentum which seems to have
happened to you so how did that happen
and how long did it take you know in
this specific case it took as long as it
took for me to find out
that i would have a sponsor who would
make it financially feasible for me
to pursue what i wanted to pursue
right so this is a bit different from
what you're describing
were you kind of telling as many people
as you could and that's how it wound its
way back to this philanthropist
because that was manif i mean it was
sort of manifested not in this the
secret sense but
he somehow heard about this stream said
i'd just love to hear you describe
how that came together sort of
accidentally and directly or otherwise
yeah it was sort of incidentally the
woman in charge of this
foundation her name is courtney welch
she
was a friend of mine as well so she knew
before she
was the one who hired me to teach these
kids
uh chess and i don't know how long after
this happened with tiger and i've been
been marinating in my spirit and you
know i was like
a caged tiger if you will and i was
talking to
to courtney about it and of course she
was the head of the foundation that dan
supported so she knew
him well so when i was talking to her i
said you know i can't believe what
would happen this this thing has really
been bothering me
and i feel like i'm not doing everything
i'm supposed to be doing
i'd really had gone to the top of
coaching like i said my kids had won
the national championships my students i
was doing commentary traveling the world
doing commentary
i'd done a cd rom by then and it felt
like i was doing everything
just peripheral to what i really wanted
to do and i was
basically letting her know that this is
where my spirit was
and she was the one who said well why
don't you just ask dan
and that hadn't even occurred to me even
though
he was just basically one degree of
separation away
i i said i don't know okay i guess and
so i just did
and very quickly he said i love this you
know you've done so much
for the kids and for our organization
i'd be happy to support you
and i feel like that's an important
thing to
like when you have a dream you're not on
an island right you're not
isolated there are people around who
will sense your sincerity
will sense your drive will sense your
determination
and sometimes it just comes together and
i feel very fortunate that this all
happened for me but
i feel like that's happened to me at
various points in my life
that a window opens because i'm
manifesting out there that this is what
i want
is it may not been a specific person to
to help sponsor me and sponsor my quest
but just
somehow it just opens and i always have
faith that something's going to happen
you just have to keep at it keep that
window that window open that spirit open
for possibility to come to you
and just don't lose that passion that
drive
because it's not happening right away
how does someone and this is as much for
me as for people listening
become rated in chess becoming a master
or grand master or anything in between
is it a function of racking up
competition points what is the process
for progressing
upward through the ranks in chess you
got to beat people
sort of comes down well
chess has a ranking system what we call
a rating system
that was uh invented by
a hungarian mathematician arpan elo
and he came up with a way of waiting
results to compare players
against other players and once you start
that
and somebody has a number and then you
play against that person
you get a certain number of points for
beating that person or for drawing that
person or
you lose points for losing to that
person and then you find out where you
are on the totem pole
and that is you know now you spread that
out to
millions of people and chess players all
around the world
get these ratings now we have class
players so
class a b c on down then you finally
becoming a title player
is when you become an expert or a master
an international master international
brand master
and you're moving up the rating scale
but again you have to do it by
beating people at that next level for
you to bring yourself up or
dominating your level which means you
don't belong in the level anymore so you
just start accumulating
a massive amount of points it's very
similar tennis uses
pretty much the same thing to get the
title officially however titles like
international master
or grand master you have to perform at a
certain level
rating level against other
internationally ranked players
and those numbers it's a again a formula
depending on who you're playing against
very specific numbers uh but man
they put that level so high that people
spend years and years of their lives
trying
to attain the norms as we call them and
you need to do it three times so imagine
taking like the bar in law and somebody
says you're gonna have to take
bart three times you're gonna have to
pass it three times
except the bar at least you can study
for and the
you know there's content on there that
you have to learn
in chess you have to deal with the fact
that whatever you know
there's somebody sitting across the
board trying to destroy you
and prove you wrong and that's a very
different kind
of ladder to have to climb so
and like no grandmaster wants to be the
one that somebody else
stepped over to become a grandmaster
themselves and so it's
it's cutthroat uh it's trial by fire
it's amazing
it's like the top black belt in karate
right your bruce lee's
imagine having to fight bruce lee if you
want to call yourself a professional
fighter
i mean that's that's the kind of stuff
you have to do
in chess and so it's it's quite a
journey
so let's talk about the dusting off the
gloves right so you
are teaching you're commentating you're
doing very well
in these various fields you've created
instructional materials
then you decide to get back get back in
the ring to
try to actualize this this dream
what does it look like to get back into
training shape so to speak what do you
do
so first things first all the chess
books
get pulled out you've got to have
material stuff to learn
at the time one great development we're
talking 1997
was computer databases
on chess so we're talking about
collections of games
of famous players or even not so famous
players
that were that were archived
and in such a way that you could
research individual players
so that meant that if i had to play tim
ferriss if he's played in a tournament
somewhere
that game gets archived i look up your
games and i say oh
so you like the sicilian defense let me
make sure i prepare because that's what
you're going to play against me when i
play you
in a couple of weeks time it's like
watching tape on a boxer
exactly right any sports game we're able
to record
all the games that's one of the great
things about chess is we have games from
hundreds of years of
games from centuries ago
right easily uh games from the 1500 the
italian players the talent school of
chess
we have games purportedly napoleon
played
and there's some doubt whether it was
him but nevertheless
all the top chess players of the past
and certainly those of the present
we have their game so that is important
because you're talking about
initially hundreds of thousands of games
now the databases are
seven million to eight million strong
meaning
number of games so what so i could
research
the best players if i'm going to play
world champion my research boom
magnus carlson's name comes up and i see
all his games but not only that i'm able
to
very easily check which which are his
favorite lines well that guy plays
everything but
you know where where does where is his
inclination
what where does he when does he lose
what kind of things happen to cause him
to lose games
uh what kind of situation am i trying to
avoid so that's when you have to really
dig deep into the psychology of the
player
through the information you're getting
from their games that's a huge part of
our preparation
and you can't do that half-heartedly you
got to be ready you got you have to you
know that's digging that's note-taking
that's research at the highest level and
you got to study your openings
so like i said so you combine openings
book study
database openings and then on top of
that you need to have a trainer
you need to have somebody who has had
great experience in chess
who may be retired now and has been
through all the wars
but now is an advisor role and you pay
him that money or pay her that money
because
they're going to say to you you know
what this situation right here you
should be doing this
this thing right here now that's not you
you should try studying that try this
this line and then you call them up you
got a big game hey what should i do in
this game i'm playing so-and-so
and they help you and you do the
research so it's all that support system
the top players have more than one
person on their team they have a team
a real team you know so you just get
that together so that you can be
prepared like like a fine-tuned assassin
ready to play
just a quick thanks to one of our
sponsors and we'll be right back to the
show
this podcast episode is brought to you
by helix sleep
sleep is incredibly important to me i
study it
i research it it is my end-all be-all it
determines so much else and i've been
sleeping on a helix
midnight luxe mattress for the last few
years i also have one in my guest
bedroom
and feedback from friends has always
been fantastic helix was selected as the
number one best overall mattress pick of
2020 by gq
wired apartment therapy and many others
just go to helixsleep.com
tim take their two-minute sleep quiz and
they'll match you to a customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life
they have a 10-year warranty and you get
to try it for 100 nights
risk-free they'll even pick it up from
you if you don't love it
and helix is offering up to 200 off all
mattress orders plus two free pillows at
helix
sleep dot com slash tim one more time
that's helix
h e l i x sleep.com
tim for up to 200 off
what does it look like to build mental
and physical stamina for the game of
chess i mean you said earlier
and it is a sport right referring to
chess i can't even conceive
of trying to
concentrate on a single game for
six hours right it's hard for me to
conceive of and i consider myself pretty
good
at focusing but when i lived in i lived
in japan as an exchange student as my
my first real exposure to any chess it
wasn't western chess but it was shogi
which is japanese chess
and then go which is a whole separate
animal and
i was toast after 30 to 60 minutes
complete toast worthless so how
do you build mental and physical stamina
for high level chess
well physical is easy you just get on
the treadmill
you go swimming you run you bike
you do whatever it is that you have a
good time doing
preferably you have a good time doing
but you make sure you get
that cardio burn because you're going to
need
reserves of energy when you're playing
for that long so
exercise is a must and you look at all
the top players now
nobody's overweight nobody's overweight
every in fact you're burning so many
calories when you're playing from the
intensity of it i know they just did a
study which i
i think is completely insane uh the
numbers that they came up with something
like 6000 calories burned during a chess
game
which i find that's it's like that
i know we're like doing a lot but that
seems like over the top
but that's essential first of all in
terms of the mental side
i think a big part of mastery in that
way
has to do with the fact that you start
experiencing it as a youngster
so you train over the years and years
and years
you learn by doing right when a kid
first starts playing chess
kids are not stopping to think like
first move that comes to mind
boom that's what i'm gonna play but so
that works for a while
and then you do that against a good
player and then you lose yeah you make a
mistake and boom you lose again
and then it's the kid that stops and
says okay i need to stop and look now
because
everest is actually threatening
something with their moves
and i need to respect that and so they
stop they start slowing down
and the more you do that the more you
start training yourself
to be more thoughtful
and respectful of your opponent
and that's the that's the building of
the discipline of the mind
that happens very early on which is why
we teach chess to kids because
that process happens automatically and
i'm sure as you said you were toast
after 35-60 minutes but if you
loved it enough or if you couldn't
tolerate that ass kicking enough
and you'd be back and back and back you
would just keep doing it and doing it
and doing it
and soon you would get that stamina so
that you could go
an hour and a half two hours two and a
half and and beyond
the other thing that some people use is
meditation and
a way of quieting the mind and the
spirit so that you can
really focus and not get ahead of
yourself when you're playing
that's a huge part of it as well that
kind of mental training
and anything you do i did aikido martial
art aikido for
some years as well and that was
extremely extremely helpful in centering
me
and getting me to to recognize the
openings that were possible
in my opponent's position that i would
be there because they were overly
aggressive
so we use every trick in the book i was
going to ask you about aikido chess
because i found a
mention of aikido chess could you
elaborate on how you tie those two
together
one of the greatest books i've ever read
is called aikido and the dynamic sphere
it's by
orati and i want to say weston but i
think i got that wrong
anyway taiquito in the dynamic sphere
and i remember
when i first stumbled on this book and
the book is
the book is about aikido but as i was
reading it i felt like i was reading
about chess
and i was really struck by that how they
were so intimately connected in the idea
of
your opponent the focus you have from
the opponent
on the attack on defense on centering
this important chest is very important
to control the center of the board
so the primacy of centralization the
dynamics
of the struggle and when i saw that
i said i gotta study ikea i gotta
actually go on the mat
and i just do this from a theoretical
standpoint and
i went fortunately there was one in my
neighborhood i went to
the dojo and it was really
life-changing it took my game to a
totally different level
just learn to recognize primarily aikido
is defensive so
aikido recognizes the flaws in attacks
and i would say like i'm from brooklyn
we had a school of chess that said
you attack that's how you go my friend
ronnie sims used to say
ever forward never backward so he's not
backing up when he's coming after you
you're supposed to die
but we you did that against the best
players and somehow
they would sidestep your attacks and
bring their pieces
inside the gaps that you left behind
and that's exactly what aikido and many
of the
soft martial arts are about is finding
the gaps and letting you get as much of
your attack as you want off
but just getting off center enough
that you miss or you barely hit
but then the return coming at you is
going to come with
tremendous force and when i was able to
physicalize that like get it into my
body and then internalize it
and then transfer that into mental
mapping onto the chessboard
my game went to a completely different
level and that really is what took me to
becoming a grandmaster as far as
you know i'm concerned because being
able to do that
meant that you had to stand in the
middle of the energy the
the tornado coming at you and just find
that that soft point
and say no i'm fine everything is okay
this attack's not going to work that was
a whole different way of thinking that i
hadn't studied before and because of it
i was able to
change the way i played and improve as a
player what was it like when you became
a grandmaster can you can you tell us
about that experience
was it all you hoped it would be were
you shocked
was it anticlimactic what was that
experience like
it was depressing it's depressing
it was depressing it's extraordinary uh
at first at first you know there was the
whirlwind of
becoming a grand master i got a lot of
press around being the first
african-american grandmaster in history
and all that
but when you're on a life quest right
you this is something that you always
dreamt about doing
every day you wake up and your north
star
is this goal right this is what you want
out of life like i want to become a
grand master
i don't care about anything else i want
to become a grandmaster i would wake up
thinking i
please don't die today maurice i don't
want to die i just want to become a
grandmaster
and that fueled my passion i mean i'm
serious about that by the way
that's all i wanted that's all i wanted
so
when i got there there's that feeling of
elation
joy uh satisfaction
relief like it had finally happened
i had many false starts i came
this close so many times only to lose
the last game
that i needed to win but i mean
it's it was such a hard climb of the
mountain but once you get to the top of
the mountain you look around you get
your chance to look
and now what like you got a nice view
that's great how long can you stay on
the mountain
you just you know that's not that's the
human mind
it doesn't work that way it's not like
you're just gonna sit there because i
have no knowledge
too yeah right uh yeah so
you need you need another mountain
and that like next six months i couldn't
find another mountain
i i was just like oh i don't have to
think about this again
there's nothing almost for me to do like
that was my thinking
it took me a while to to stop and say
you know what you can just become a
better player
maybe focus on the world championship
title i was already 33 years old
uh late to the game as it was starting
chest of 14 that's already
geriatric as far as chess is concerned
so
the odds weren't high that i was going
to become a world champion let's put it
that way the hearts were like
slim to to none but you need a goal
you need something that even if it's
unreachable it drives you
and so when i reset that goal
allowed me to now say let's become
better let's get better again
and i refound my love for the game
beyond
the competitive drive and the goal
setting
that i had and in many ways that was
more beautiful than
the goal itself because it was a
rekindling
of why i played the game in the first
place and
one of the great truths that i learned
in becoming a grandmaster is that i was
a beginner again
and that beginner's mind has never left
me
i'm still fascinated by the game we're
talking about 20 years later
i'm still fascinated by little things
about the game
that just continue to amaze me that it's
possible on the chessboard
and that evergreen freshness that chess
has
is what draws us in and uh it's
made me happy all these decades let's
talk about beauty
and captivation because
uh i'd like to take that lens and apply
it to coaching
and teaching you've had some very
successful students very successful
teams
how do you hook kids on chess how do you
make it
captivating how do you help them see the
beauty
what what have you learned in all of
your teaching and what and also what are
what were some of the names of the
teams the raging rooks that was a great
team
that was my best team in fact uh they
won a middle school championship in
1991.
straight out of harlem my teams were
both teams were out of harlem
and we didn't have any stars on our team
we didn't have
big time players masters and the like we
just had kids who loved the game
and had passion and heart and
would listen to whatever i told them to
do uh the
dark knights were another team that we
had
and same deal and for me it really
wasn't
about creating stars or
even winning a national championship
again the idea of setting a goal
is important because it allows you to
focus
but you asked me what i learned the two
things i learned
from coaching number one i was very
lucky
that what i was coaching was chess
because the
the activity was the real drive
chess is just a great game i think this
is a great game it's been around for
1500 years
because it's a great game it doesn't get
old we're living in a video game age and
yet chess is
thriving online i mean chess with kovid
shutting everything down
chess tournaments are bigger than ever
chess participation
is bigger than ever people are following
chess players now
like like like never before ikaru
nakamura went from
he's a top player went from like 10 000
followers on twitch
to almost half a million i mean
holy cow yeah i mean that's like just in
the last handful of months
exactly wow it's been amazing
incredible because people are inside and
they want something fun to do it
it's not just fun but meaningful right
something they think
kids are going to have not just a good
time but not waste their time they're
going to learn from it and so
chess has just exploded online it's
incredible
so the game holds
an eternal fascination for the human
mind
and it really is a part of world culture
played in all all countries everywhere
the international chess federation has
over 200 country
membership i mean it's just really
ubiquitous game and so for me it's easy
when i put chess in front of kids
because they're going to be fascinated
you got the chess pieces the king and
queen and brooks and knights
bishops and pawns they got these shapes
you've got the board
and kids just want to touch and feel and
move
and what do what do these pieces do so
the love of the thing itself
is critical the love of the thing itself
and as a teacher what's critical
is the love and passion of the teacher
because
if you're just teaching people if you're
just there
to make a buck uh if you feel obligated
to do it
people pick that up right away kids pick
that up even quicker
it's when they see how much you're on
fire about what you do when you're fresh
to it
that other people say hey i want a piece
of this
i'm listening to this guy i want to
learn
you know i had so much fun coaching
chess to my students
for me it was sports i'd be i'd be
bringing in basketball i would bring it
in martial arts
i'd be bringing in trash talking no you
saw a good move and i'd be like that was
juice
that was juice and then they started
quoting me oh that was a juice move
right there
you know the teacher brings that energy
teacher brings the passion and i think
when when that happens
it's easy to take people to the next
level because they can feel you
they can feel that you love what you do
and you really want to impart this to
them and for me that makes
that made and makes talking about chess
really a simple affair because i've got
one of the greatest pieces of world
culture
that is perennially fascinating and then
i got the fact that i'm in love with it
so you combine that and people want to
hear it online
what would your advice be to someone
like me or anyone listening
who is hearing your descriptions your
life story
and wants to give chess a shot in the
sense that
they really want to actually dedicate
some time
to become a competent
not necessarily a hyper competitive
chess player but a competent chess
player
what would you suggest they do easy
these days
everything's online everything's online
you got great websites
you have chess.com which has resources
up the wazoo
very inexpensive to get whether it's
puzzles whether it's
videos instructional videos whether it's
being able to watch
tournaments whether it's playing anyone
from all around the world there are
millions of people online all the time
you can just challenge them to a game
anytime you want it's a quick game you
can play
five minute blitz you can play ten
minutes you just tailor it according to
how much time you have
uh that's one website leeches.org is
another great website
how do you spell that lis lichest.org
i mean though those sites have really
done it right
uh in such a way uh as to has to give
you
everything you could possibly want so
you can learn chess better there's
another site chess24.com
just two the numbers two and four dot
com
you get professional folks you get the
world champion on there a lot
you can watch the top level play with
top level commentary
once you get to that level of interest
i mean it's amazing how chess has
teleported itself online in this way
but seamlessly seamlessly if
i had these kind of resources when i was
in brownsville
oh my goodness i might have turned into
a player
[Laughter]
are there any you mentioned puzzles are
those situational
exercises where you are effectively in a
preset situation on a board and have to
in x number of moves do y something like
that is that what you mean by puzzles
yeah but you made it sound so boring no
well i i don't mean to make it sound
boring i mean when i when i was in
uh japan this is a long time ago i was
15 but
there's uh there's something called
tsumeshogi which is
i'm trying to figure out if it's the
same thing which is a book
of these exercises all right here's the
situation
what do you do and i found it completely
addictive
i found it fascinating it is and it's
the best thing about
about chess is when you get to look
to see how you would win the game if we
watch
lebron james go up for a shot right
and he he does like a 360 puts it
between his legs
switch to his left hand and dunk it
right
flush all you can do is go wow
but you're not doing that but in chess
we have the opportunity to take a
position where one of the greatest
players of all time may have been
behind either the white or the black
pieces and
it says okay you get to be gary caspara
or magnus carlsen or paul morphy or
alexander
alekhine you get to be that person right
now
what's the brilliant move to win or
series of moves
and you sit there yeah you know you
figure out when you sit there for a
while and you can't really figure it out
then
finally you do this calculation that you
try this you try that and then you
realize
what it is and usually it's just a work
of art
and you're able to copy that yourself
but you feel like a genius after that no
what a great feeling
i could play like him right but
yeah not really you got to get that
positioned yourself
that's the hard part but it's so much
fun
it's so much fun to be able to to get
inside the minds of
the great geniuses do you have any
favorite a favorite books related to
chess
if somebody wanted to in addition to the
websites
and electronic tools to have something
to
take with them on a trip or
on a weekend when they want to kind of
in an analog way dig into chess do any
resources come to mind
i mean there's so many great books out
there uh
my friend grandmaster yasuceron did a
great series
called the winning chess series winning
chess
strategies winning chess tactics really
lucidly explained
simple language great little situations
for you to learn a lot from i think that
series
was very very popular it's published by
microsoft
way back when but it's definitely and i
think it's
i think that i could list a lot of books
but
that series was pretty spot-on and we'll
link to those
in the show notes we'll find the proper
links to everything we've been talking
about and put those in the show notes
for this episode
let's continue with books so one of the
one of the bullets
that i have here for discussion
is the importance of biographies can you
expand on this please
yes absolutely biographies are
some of the most inspirational materials
out there
i think people people read different
things right but if you really want to
to know the journey the path to mastery
the path to becoming a champion the
obstacles that you may have to overcome
how to deal with those obstacles there's
nothing like
reading the lives of great people and
it's almost like the secret sauce for
success
along the lines of motivation and
deep learning deep patterning i remember
when i read
jackie robinson's autobiography and
i was reading it actually on a plane to
germany where i would play in a
in a big tournament that ended up giving
me the second step
the second norm we call it out of the
three norms that i needed to become a
grandmaster
we were reading it on the way uh on that
plane and then finally finishing it up
after i landed and i was back in the
hotel and i was so inspired by his
journey
because here i was trying to become the
first
african-american grandmaster in chess
history
and i'm reading about this man who had
broken the color line in baseball
and the challenges that he faced i faced
some racism myself but
it paled in comparison
to what he faced like i couldn't even
talk about my experiences
when you when you look you listen to the
people putting a black cat on the field
calling him the n word left right and
center just you know screaming
spewing hated him from the stands
and then his dignity and strength in
dealing with that
it just was so absolutely inspiring that
fortitude
that it took that mental toughness to be
able to
to stand up to that and still perform at
the highest level win rookie of the year
and end up winning a world series for
the dodgers
i mean just even thinking about it right
now i'm
you know feeling inspired inside but
those kinds of materials that's what
i think really is a secret recipe for
growth
uh along the path to success and i think
it's extremely important to find
those stories and read them and study
them and because you'll
you'll call on them on your quest your
journey you're calling them
along the way you'll remember something
will be happening to you and you'll
remember
oh i read about this happened to this
person there's nothing like learning
from other people's experiences do you
have any other
favorite biographies or biographies that
come to mind that have
made a an indelible impression on you in
some fashion
uh the one that jumps to my head is
another great african-american frederick
douglass and
he had it even worse than jackie did and
going back in time obviously frederick
douglass was
in the 19th century i don't even
understand how he became what he became
i really don't i anything about somebody
who was a slave for the first 20 years
of their lives
and to teach himself how to read
and then to become so well spoken so
articulate
so learned to stand up
after having been beaten to a pulp so
many times
uh finally escape of course and then to
go on
with little bitterness in his heart to
fight for
a cause that is simply an eternal one
right one one of the great causes of of
humanity
to fight for the for the liberty of
human bodies i mean i i really just sit
in awe
at the grandeur of someone like
frederick douglass he's one of my
favorite
people are in history and he's one of
those people you say okay who you want
to go back and meet and sit down and
talk to
please give me three days i need three
days with frederick douglass
and his biography is really what what
makes me want to do this particularly
the second one
uh he has three autobiographies right
those that he wrote there's a great
biography on him also by david blight
that's like the definitive one but he
wrote his own as well
that's he was just remarkable what was
it about the second autobiography that
struck you uh it was fresh it was fresh
to what he was experiencing
by the time he got to his third one he
was already
sort of seeing it through the lens of
his experiences
uh and that was many years later
but the second one was enough of
his life out of freedom that
he was able to um to really describe it
in a fresh way
and you just think about what you know
humans have to go through
i just i can't understand it i sit today
you know with the social unrest that's
going on in the us
now uh but i sit today
thinking about what happened to
african americans at that time
and i just i don't i don't understand
how you know
people people kept their chins up
you know you're working as slaves you're
working for someone
your entire life your entire life all
you know
is working for someone else with no
compensation
how do you do that for hundreds of years
how do you do that i i
how do families tolerate that and then
you can get beaten at
any moment on the whim of your master
you move to the to the rhythm of someone
else's drum
you get sold if they choose to do so
you're separated from your family
members
if they choose to do so and somehow
you're not suicidal right depressed at
least
how do you keep your head up how do you
keep your head up and
and forge a destiny for the future
generations
and produce people like frederick
douglass
or harriet tubman it's stunning to me
it's absolutely stunning i think it's a
story that
is not truly well told in schools
deserves to be because it was just
absolutely
beyond comprehension and so inspiring
yeah incredibly so if you're open to it
could you speak to your
personal experience or observations
related to the current moment
you mentioned the social unrest the
current moment
current events what do you use what are
you seeing and experiencing
i've been really down i guess it's both
ways you know down
about all that's going on right now that
we could be in 2020 and that this
discussion is
so relevant as though we're back 60
years ago
back a hundred years ago like issues
that that a frederick douglass would
notice and say what
you guys haven't solved this yet are you
serious i think that the reason for that
is because what happened in the society
is
essentially america try to solve a
problem by legislating it
and as denzel washington said you can't
legislate
love right you can't legislate respect
you can try to legislate fairness
but you can't make everyone everywhere
get on that same page so laws were put
into effect like when
the 13th amendment 14th amendment 15
amendment happened and then the
reconstruction happened for the brief
time that it did
but then people's hearts hadn't changed
so
immediately after reconstruction came
this redemption period in the south
where they just simply undid all the
benefits
of those amendments and carried out
terrorist campaigns against african
americans
through uh intimidation through burning
down homes
through burning down neighborhoods like
in tulsa
uh through lynchings and the like
that that set it all back and you're
putting in
clauses anti-voting clauses making it
very difficult to vote if your
grandfather
hadn't voted then you couldn't vote well
of course my grandfather was a slave of
course he couldn't vote
now all these impediments to keep
african americans down and then you fast
forward to 1965 6465 and you get the
civil rights act and voting rights act
and those are again implemented as
federal laws but you
can't legislate that on the ground
people
would necessarily embrace
this principle and begin to carry it out
in every way the nefarious fingers of of
segregation and racism
had entrenched themselves in such a way
as to make it
very very difficult to undo so a lot of
people want to hope that
these laws somehow changed everything
fundamentally and there have definitely
been changes i mean you can go to a
hotel now
in places you couldn't before you eat
lunch calendars you couldn't et cetera
but so many other issues remain uh
whether it was in fair housing because
of redlining
african americans couldn't get loans for
homes
whether it's uh education
because if you live in a poor
neighborhood your your taxes pay
for your school but your school is going
to obviously be underfunded because
you're in a poor neighborhood uh or
whether it's
incarceration where african-americans
are incarcerated at a greater rate
than others and then this current issue
of police brutality
and if these things weren't literally
attacked like you know to so you could
address them comprehensively
then they weren't going to be solved
it's really that simple they simply
weren't going to be solved
we sort of hope for a certain
evolutionary effect if you will like it
it will happen
over time the law is there is there in
place
therefore now everything else was going
to
undo itself magically and what
history has shown is that it just didn't
and
sooner or later you'll have these
flare-ups
that show the inequities that exist
and if the greater society that is the
majority in this country
doesn't feel impassioned to make the
change happen
the change won't happen it's just the
tyranny of the majority
you know as alexander tuckerville said
uh democracy has its tyrants as well
and the tyrants are actually the people
the majority of the people
the majority doesn't feel that an issue
is that important
they won't address it because they don't
see it as a problem
and until the majority sees it as a
problem and embraces it and now wants
laws to
effectuate that it simply will
not change that's the only way it
changes is the majority
gets on board with it and a minority
group can fight for those things but
they can't vote it the way they want it
to go they can't
legislate out those things out of
existence because they're simply
always going to lose the vote so i think
as great as democracy is this one
fundamental issue
that the majority so natural right
majority
usually is supposed to win if there's 10
of us 10 buddies
and eight of us want to go to the movies
and two of us want to go hiking it's
eight of us want to go to the movies
that's what's gonna happen it's so
natural
that you don't think about it it's just
the way things function
but we have a responsibility anywhere
there's a majority i don't care where it
is the us
any any you know it could be nigeria
wherever it is
the majority has a responsibility
to very carefully address the concerns
of the minority
uh because otherwise you turn into
tyrants without knowing it but just
just taking care of your family like you
take care of yourself your family and
your friends that's all you need to do
yourself your family and your friends
but once that is amplified to those like
you
you're turning to tyrants without
knowing it
so we're dealing with that right now and
i'm not sure where it's going to end up
you're old enough you feel like
yeah maybe there's going to be change if
you're young
you feel like yes it's a time for it but
we have to see how it shakes out thank
you for sharing all that
and elucidating it i mean and certainly
giving voice to it so so well are there
any
particular changes or any particular
actions that you would
like to see in the next say two to three
years if you
could direct things in any way do any
particular
changes come to mind that you would like
to see
is it more a cultural shift that needs
to happen by attention being paid by
a majority to the the plight and
inequities
that affect the minority are there any
other particular examples
that come to mind for you yeah so that
first one is big right that's where it
all starts
if the majority doesn't realize or it
doesn't take an interest
doesn't care doesn't focus on the
concerns of the minority
and again minority in any sense then
whoever has to vote wins right and so
that has to be where a mental shift
takes place
that's where it all starts in in terms
of
legal structure
and then in terms of specific concrete
steps that can be taken
so i can start talking about you know
you need to address
over-incarceration of young black men or
you need to address
racism in police departments even if
it's
just a small percentage but that small
percentage needs to be rooted out
uh aggressively and you can't have
good cops ignoring bad cops right i
don't care if it's
if you might say whatever percentage you
know the percentage paid
we don't know the percentage but let's
let's say it's 98
that two percent has to be weeded out
aggressively you need to address
the stress that police officers are
dealing with when they're on
on the job you know it's an extremely
high stress position
give them help give them an evaluation
uh maybe they need a little extra time
off
whatever it is to make sure that they're
coming to communities
whole and healthy and and ready to be
champions of justice that we expect them
to be
so you know that's that's specific areas
of concern
we can address i think that for me the
two big ones are
police tactics and education
i came from a family that said you pull
yourself up by the brute straps you work
your tail off
you will be successful that was our
formula right
but you can't have structural
impediments that stop that from
happening
and the reason why policing is so
important
is because police have the right to take
life
they're the only group in society that
just has the right to take your life
on a judgment call of somebody who might
have just
joined the force and maybe 22 years old
but has to make a snap decision and just
makes it and then this person's lost
their life
so that's important because it's
traumatizing the community when that
happens if it happens unfairly it
happens regularly and unfairly
even in perception that's traumatizing
to the community because
when one black person feels under siege
i guarantee you the larger group feels
under siege and i don't want to think
about my son walking down the street
my beautiful son who just graduated high
school and has all the aspirations to
become an artist and then somehow gets
mistreated a certain way
i couldn't survive life if something
happened to him
just i couldn't imagine anything right
so
it's important that that is a place
where we feel
safe we feel respected we feel like
justice is properly served
by those who are champions of justice
you want to look at every police officer
and say
this person's a champion of justice
they're a hero
and when you see stuff like what
happened with george floyd and the
person on this guy
who i won't name we know his name but i
don't want to
honor him as such putting a knee on a
man's neck for nine minutes
you're not a champion of justice then
the rest of us have to watch that and
the rest of us are traumatized by that
and one of those are anger and now
there's
a reaction we've got to get to that good
place right we've got to get stagnant
and education the inequities in
education everybody knows it
everybody on any side of the aisle knows
it people are trying different things
whether
you know republicans who believe in
choice or
you know loosely speaking and democrats
believe in public school and improving
that
i don't care what it is that cannot be
unfair
because that's going to keep a group
down there are other things as well
of course but to me those are the two
major areas
of concern i'd love to see great
movement on both of those
as i watch right now i'm just i'm i'm
concerned
i'm concerned because now you're we're
also living with covid
and attention shifts easily
i don't know that the results will come
but i think if we have good minded
people who feel like they
they really want to see change happen
and i love the fact that corporations
are
are
jumping in on this as well it probably
has to be private because when it's
it's government uh you know question
mark question mark question mark
each person has to be in the middle of
this fight on the education front
i mean you've spent time as a as an
educator as a teacher as a coach
are there any particular problems that
you saw
within the systems that you were part of
or
challenges or handicaps or opportunities
that stood out to you or particular
challenges that kids
you were working with faced that perhaps
were
unaddressed does anything come to mind
when i ask those questions
i was like well how long a list do you
want me to
put together i mean the biggest thing is
lack of resources or good resources
in a school right if you don't have
a lot of money the school doesn't have
the
top computers that it needs so kids can
go in that
that room and use those computers
the school doesn't have the latest books
for kids to read or enough books so that
every kid
can have a book the kid teachers are
facing
this every single day in neighborhoods
all across america
and it's sad i mean it's completely
ridiculous when i came to this country
for us it was a joke the american school
system
because i came to the country from
jamaica where i went to one of the top
schools i tested into one of the top
schools
i spent a year as wilmer's boys high
school
but i was only 12. i was 11 when i got
in 12 when i came here
and i tested into the top
class in my middle school
i took a reading test the school
guidance counselor whoever it was
i remember her just having me do a
reading test i was reading on a 12th
grade level
great you belong with special kids the
smartest kids in the school
this is the top class this is where
these kids are like the kids on track
to success and i went into class that
first day
and when i was done with the day i went
up to my mother i said i don't belong in
this class
because the stuff we're learning in this
class i already learned in jamaica
this was like like the beginning of last
year in jamaica like this is
this stuff is too easy and my mother she
didn't know how to work the system she
finally had kids like in school in
america so she gave
me a report card to take to the teacher
and to the guidance counselor so i i
took it and i said look
i was stopping my class in jamaica and
she's like
what is this no you are in the best
class you're 12 years old
seventh grade you're in the best class
that's it now imagine
that tiny jamaica tiny poor
no you name it right country of jamaica
is producing
basic education or good education
that i'm in the best school in the hood
the best class that is the best class in
the school
and we're woefully these kids are
woefully
underprepared and they're the smartest
kids they're not
we ended up all by the way skipping
eighth grade we jumped from seventh
grade to ninth grade because
they knew it was a waste of the time for
us to be in the eighth grade class
if we were going through that imagine
what the other kids were going through
the kids who were not in our
class kids were on the slow track or the
let's call it the normal track okay
a whole generation of kids under
prepared
for the challenges that they have to
face and through no fault of their own
this is a systemic problem and
unless this is addressed systematically
then you continue to have this this
challenge in preparing
our kids the vast majority of kids not
the special feud
for life in the 20th century for elite
jobs
or top leadership positions it's
unacceptable and so to me
that's really where that gap is and
i don't know i mean it's obvious how to
solve it
you gotta you just gotta go in there and
improve schools
top to bottom by the way kovit has
really exposed the inequities of this
uh my ex-wife is the head of a
department
that has quality control in school
systems
and we're talking she's just shaking her
head saying
all of a sudden everybody realizes how
unequal
it is what kids are going through kids
we're supposed to be learning from home
but don't own a laptop or if they're
home
with two or three brothers and sisters
there's only one laptop in the house
so how are they all learning from the
same laptop
when there's only one in the home and
then they're dealing
if they do have it with poor wi-fi
because
mom and dad can't afford that there's
also some basic inequities that
across the board that people are now
having to deal with
now that this pandemic has hit us their
eyes are open saying oh my god how are
we going to teach these kids
and for the next we're talking about
potentially for the next year and a half
these kids are going to fall behind even
further
it's it's heartbreaking yeah it's
a terrifying and awful prospect and
like you said i think kovid and all the
recent events have
act as a kind of a force multiplier on
the pressure in the container
and have shown the cracks just how
severe and how many of them there are as
you're talking i want to mention two
organizations that people might want to
check out they're not
systemic solutions in other words
they're not
top to bottom fixes but i do think they
are of
great value one is donorschoose.org
which allows you to help provide
resources
to teachers specifically who are
under-resourced with kids
who need basic materials in many cases
they don't have
bricks they don't have pens uh and
uh donors choose i'm very very confident
and i'm
very confident both these organizations
have been involved with them for a long
time
the second is quest bridge and you can
find donorschoose.org
at donorschoose.org not surprisingly
questbridge.org is another
and quest bridge
is very good and very
innovative in how they connect and
source talent
from underserved communities so
economically disadvantaged communities
and so on
and match them with scholarships to top
tier
colleges and universities because it's
not a it's not
exclusively a funding problem with
respect to scholarships
it's often a talent sourcing and
matching problem
and they're very very
smart about how they do this just to
give one example that i remember
really caught my attention when i met
michael mccullough who's one of the
founders these are both non-profits and
massively successful and very lean and
he was explaining that you know many of
these kids don't have the
social support that one
would hope for in terms of academic or
life
aspirations right so the idea even if
they have the intellectual horsepower
and the drive and the dedication to
apply to say a harvard
just does not exist in terms of their
inputs and
so what they've done in a number of
cases is for instance
they'll provide an ipad giveaway and
they'll promote an ipad
new ipad giveaway and the application
form for the giveaway unbeknownst to the
kids who fill it out
doubles as a standardized application
that can be sent
to 20 different colleges and then
several months later these kids get a
letter in the mail saying
sorry you didn't win the ipad but by the
way you have a free ride to amherst or
whichever school event it is i like that
yeah
it's uh it's it's really amazing so i
don't wanna don't hog the microphone
here but those are
those are two i know much less about
criminal justice reform i have friends
who focus on that i know much less about
police
both training and self-policing
and all the facets of that but on the
education side those are two
that are are really worth taking a look
at for folks
and even if they're treated as a stop
gap measure they actually do
deliver results maurice you you strike
me as someone who
thinks very deeply i mean you do think
very deeply you ask
a lot of questions of yourself you sort
of interrogate reality or your
perception of reality
could you speak to of two books
here that you've mentioned and mentioned
in tribe of mentors
where you appeared as a profile which i
i very much appreciate you doing
and there are two books i'd love for you
to speak to as is having an impact on
you
passages and i think it's gail sheehy is
that how you pronounce the last name
s-h-e-e-h-y and mastery by george
leonard
could you speak to those two absolutely
passages i read that book as a teenager
late teenager 18 or 19. i just gone
through a
pretty rough period of changing actually
i can't even call it changing
literally dropping friends in my life
because i felt like
those friends weren't about what i
wanted to do
and i felt i needed to go in a different
direction and so it was a lonely period
for me a transition
between great friends and and
the next set of friends that i would
have and this book
uh passages was about the passages of a
man's life
and so essentially gail sheehy
she just went from your from a man from
his teenage years or his 20s
all the way to old age every decade
giving them broad strokes of what would
happen
to you as a man during those decades
of course you can be specific
everybody's gonna have their own
experiences but you know by and large
you're gonna
go out and get work you're going to go
out of school you're going to go get
work you're going to
try to establish yourself somewhere
along the line you're going to get a
significant other
especially you're going to have children
you're going to go through that father
period
some some place you're going to have a
little age crisis somewhere uh
along the way uh your identity is gonna
shift a few times uh as you challenge
yourself
and then at some point you're gonna
become settled in who you are you're
gonna come to a different level of
acceptance
and settle who you are and start to
accept the world
for what it is and where you and your
place in it
and then there's a certain kind of peace
and
and comfort that comes with becoming
older and recognizing
life the kind of wisdom that you get i
was fascinated by this it was almost
like a
like she was analyzing life like a chess
player you know
like seeing them analyzing it all the
way down
down to the end game and i wanted from
that book i wanted to have the wisdom
of the 70 year old and the 80 year old
as an 18 year old i was like wait a
minute if that's what i'm that's the end
game i want to have it now
i want to learn that now so i've always
respected
older people from from that
it made me really respect older people
because they were at a different point
along the passage
and i wanted to listen to the older guys
talk like what what's up what's
what's this like what's that like uh
it just made me even more thoughtful you
know more wise about the journey
it doesn't necessarily solve the problem
it's not like when i was
25 i had it all down pat no way
you have to get through it yourself but
but it just
helps so much to think about it
in the long term and not just what's
happening to you right at this moment
you know this too will change the other
book
mastery by george leonard george leonard
was
an aikido practitioner and he brought
the principles of aikido
into life in that small book
and talked about mastery the different
different obstacles to mastery you know
folks who just want to get it done
quickly people just want to hear the
secrets
uh people who give up for various
reasons where the obstacles where the
traps
you might fall into but the biggest
lesson of that book
was that the journey was more important
than the destination right and that you
would plateau
that you would have to love the plateau
sometimes on the path to mastery you're
just going to get stuck you're not
getting any better you're working your
ass off and you're not getting any
better
what's going on well it's not a linear
trajectory this is how it works yours
grow every single day
sometimes you have to go your studies
and your work causes you to actually
lose ability lose specific efficacy
because you're trying out new techniques
it's like tiger woods when he decided to
reconstruct his swing despite the fact
that he was the best player on the
planet
but he wanted to reconstruct the swing
and maybe lose more tournaments
but at the end of that reconstruction of
the swing when all of it
became natural suddenly he was
superman like what happened here
how do you how do you do that there was
no complacency
where he was and that is because you
have to
enjoy that process and love the plateau
you may not be getting better which if
as long as you're doing the work
everything's fine uh that those those
two books
really had impact i have to say think
about me
that i feel a lot in my life like i'm
i'm like keanu reeves in the matrix
when you know like when you you get
you get programmed because so many
people describe you as morpheus
so yeah i like when you identify with
neo yeah i mean
it's like you know you you get the
program put it in all of a sudden i know
kung fu
right that line like to me when i read a
book when i read a book that's how it is
i start reading a book and then i'm like
oh
damn that makes a lot of sense gotta
make some changes
right i'm very impressionable that way
that
you tell me something deep i mean your
book for our work week
i mean i was a riot i mean you wrecked
my life for a while
frankly you literally wrecked my life
for a while
because because i was looking at my life
like you know what
this man is right and this life i'm
living is unacceptable
i can't do this anymore this has to
change everything about it has to change
and
you know when you got a wife and kids
the missus is not hearing that right
what what what do you mean four hour
work week what are you talking about
you don't want to do what you're doing
anymore how are you going to get paid
you know you could get into some serious
arguments and i did
trying to just up end your existence
because you just read a book by some guy
who said you know you only have to work
four hours a week
but anyway i really feel that it's
important
to be flexible to embrace uncertainty
there's always been hallmarks for me i
don't really know
i don't really know i'm just observing
this is what i'm thinking at the moment
it may change
as i get more facts i don't really know
i don't want you to know what i'm going
to say before i say it
you know because i'm so predictable i
don't want to live in that strict level
i want to be the person you say really
what made you change so much why are you
living this life
and now i'm actually living that life by
the way i got to that point
um where i'm doing exactly what i want
to do i have
unlimited time i choose the gigs i do
i'm traveling the world
i mean last year i gave up my apartment
i've been 15 months of vagabond
i've traveled all over man so i've been
everywhere i've been
a few countries in africa i've been all
over europe
i'm just living totally out of my
suitcases it's
so liberating and wonderful well it
matches the embracing uncertainty right
i mean you're
moving with the winds and the tides and
also your passions
it would seem that's that's at least
yeah absolutely and it's also
and it's also a nod to minimalism
because
when you're living out of suitcases they
want it to be 50 pounds
like this is not 50 pounds take
whatever is in here and put it in your
other your small bag
it's like i need everything that i have
with me man what do you mean you know
tim ferriss says i can i'm supposed to
have this
i'm kidding but you know you've got to
you've got to deal with what you've got
and so my stuff is in storage
there's going to come a point where i i
figure out a place i want to be
i put my headquarters if you will a
jumping off point a place my kids can
come visit and put their feet up
but for now it's just absolutely
liberating to just floating and going
with the winds
although i got to tell you that damn
covet breeze is no fun
that is putting a damper on the travel
like nobody's business
and so i i've got to respect that for
now at least
until we resolve this one it does clip
the wings a little bit
might mean more time on the feet
we're on the tires well maurice i always
enjoy spending time with you and
this has been a long time coming i'm
embarrassed that it took me
this long but i really appreciate you
and the perspectives that you bring to
bear
and also you mentioned it almost in
passing but
i think it's a hallmark of a partner
that moves in lockstep with the
curiosity that drives
so much of what you love and also so
much of what you're good at and that is
the
willingness to say i don't know that
is it's i don't know if you
realize and you probably do how
uncommon that is that people like to
know
that what i've observed and many of the
people i respect most
is you know the more they learn the more
they realize they don't know
and i'm continually impressed by
your willingness to say i don't know and
not to use that
as a sort of metaphorical armchair of
complacency but as a
jumping off point right that's a those
are like the starting blocks
and uh it's something that i admire
a lot in you and no doubt that's
something that you've transmitted to
your students and hopefully to a lot of
people who are listening
so i really appreciate you taking the
time to have this conversation i have
one more question for you
that i must ask and that is where does
dancing and salsa fit into all this
you gotta have fun man what do you mean
you've gotta enjoy life by the way
before i answer that question
there is a book uh called the half
life of facts
half-life effects by samuel armstrong um
it the subtitle is why everything we
know has an expiration date
i like that a great book
for what you just talked about because
what you think you know
has become history 10 years ago right
you know we knew pluto
was a planet we just i still know pluto
is a planet right it's
it's nine not eight kids today already
know they've already
are incorporated into the system they'll
never make the mistake to call it a plan
the facts are are changing under our
feet
and we don't see it until it experiences
its half-life
and then suddenly the tallest building
in the world that you know i knew was
one thing
is no longer that tallest building in
the world anymore or science moves on
from what i thought was one theory and
another theory
there's a certain predictability in fact
to this the life
of so-called facts
and what it does when you think of that
concept
is that it humbles you it humbles you
into realizing that
the knowledge base that you think you're
accumulating i mean any specialist in
in fields know this is constantly
happening right doctors are are
constantly upgrading
what they know because i don't want the
guy who only
read the handbook from 1980 right i want
the guy who's looking at the 2020
2021 stuff so we are
always behind the times
we are always that's just the way it
works so
for me the thing i want is process
i want to be open i want to be flexible
right i want to keep
an uncertain mind i want to be as
least prejudicial as i can be so that
when that
new interesting data comes in i'm ready
to throw
everything out that i thought and
embrace this new idea
that's that's my my hallmark my
intellectual approach
to everything at least it's what i want
for myself
it ain't easy right obviously because
you you want something certain
somewhere you know stuff in your brain
but i think what i want to know more
than anything
is how to process information
right that's that's what i want i want
to have how to process new information
as it comes in
to be able to judge properly to not be
biased
one way or the other i don't want to be
predictable i
i just don't want you to know exactly
what i'm going to say before i say
it because that's what you knew i said
20 years ago
i i can be different i can be completely
changed that's cool it means i'm growing
and we're all growing
i don't want to be the same person i was
at 30 thinking i knew it all
and i'm the same person in 50. no way
i've grown way beyond that
now one of the ways i've grown of course
is with salsa dancing and bachata
uh i love to dance i've danced
just music itself you know for a long
time but
but in the last six or seven years i saw
a friend of mine doing salsa and he
convinced me to start it and i fell in
love with it
latin music which added to them being
latin culture
i'm totally immersed in studying spanish
right now i studied spanish back in
middle school in the worst way you could
study you know how we study
languages and we forget that stuff now
i'm immersed
myself i'm personally investing like i'm
studying chess is how much i'm studying
spanish
i'm watching uh mexican telenovelas
i'm taping them so i wait a minute what
i closed captioned
okay what was that word all right let's
go boom meantime i'm watching the story
i mean i'm hooked man i'm so hungry and
it's it's very funny to see but like to
me
that's how you stay fresh that's how you
stay fresh now i've studied
french as well my father lives in france
so i visit him and
been to paris many times for chess so
for me travel learning languages and
exploring
the world is my greatest joy really
that's my greatest joy in life
and part of it is the dancing and
there's nothing like
having something like salsa and bachata
which is which is a
different form of latin dance which is
my favorite one over salsa in fact
but there's nothing like having that
wherever you go because it's just like
chess i can always find a game
find a club where people play chess in
any country i go to i can always find a
salsa club
always always so wherever i am i'm
making friends
and i love it yeah
you're going to get all sorts of
interesting slang and the mexican
telenovelas
and uh there's also a there's a spanish
podcast made by duolingo that you might
want to check out it's
also really really helpful i ended up
with a
somewhat hilarious mongrel version of
spanish from
spending time in argentina which has a
very very particular
accent to it and grammar to it
uh but uh
i love it i love it you i i would
imagine at some point you're going to
find your way to cuba
oh yeah i've not yet been but
if i can't help you with the salsa but
if i can help in any way with the
spanish please let me know
and this is just great maurice uh i hope
we get to hang again in person
at some point soon and people can find
you i hope they find you check you out
maurice ashley.com they can find you on
twitter at maurice ashley
and i'll include links to all this at
tim dot blog forward slash podcast
actually
you will have your own url which is for
the show notes of this episode tim dot
blog forward slash maurice
and then on facebook it's grandmaster
maurice a
instagram maurice ashley chess of course
i'll link to all of this
and i will also link to the
the video clip from the tv show
where you are just in jedi fashion
going toe-to-toe with this trash talker
in your city in the park which
is just an incredible video everybody
should watch it it's it's one of my
favorite pieces of television and
i'm biased of course because it was on
the show but it's
just fantastic so that i got to tell you
i got to tell you it's funny because
the only reason i was in that park was
because you
were playing one of those hustlers
yourself
and i remember when your producer said
uh tim's going to study chess for two
weeks and then go try to play
one of those hustlers and i was like
really good luck with that
he's in trouble uh you had some trouble
you had your hands full
with oh yeah i had my hands full yeah
yeah i had my hands well there yeah that
was
not all these episodes uh turned uh
turned out with me
on top of a float going down a parade
and after my
victory lap and also that episode
included a a disproportionate amount of
ass whipping and receiving ass whippings
because not only
was there the chess piece which was just
like jumping into the deep end without
checking the depth head first
there was the jiu jitsu bees at you know
josh and marcelo garcia's school
and i just got manhandled i got
completely demolished
so if anyone wants to see all sorts of
of pain and injury uh
mental and physical then that's a good
episode maurice is there anything else
you would like to
like to say before we wrap up only that
i appreciate you man
i appreciate what you're doing uh
watching you
over the years seeing
how you've remained intellectually
curious and
the way you open open up you know your
your home if you will online that is
with your hospitality to people
people to express these great ideas that
they have
you you are a connector and a revealer
and you do it through your intellectual
curiosity i think that's just a
wonderful thing so keep up the great
work and
i'm grateful because you have influenced
me so much like i said you wrecked my
life but that's a good thing
i appreciate that that's what i want
from
people i call my friends i i
you know that's that's a good thing like
just
upend all the the bs just come on
get that out of the way and get to the
real stuff
that's what you want from somebody so
keep wrecking people's lives man
just keep doing it it's it's a good
thing
it's a good thing i'm proud of you for
it uh
just just reconstructing the swing just
reconstructing the swing that's all
that's
it yeah exactly
well i uh i appreciate you as well
and uh i really have enjoyed this
conversation and i
know people listening will as well i'll
link to everything at tim. blog forward
slash maurice
and i can't wait to hang in person soon
we can go dancing maybe even
speak some spanish depending on where we
might find ourselves
and to everybody listening
as i mentioned you can find the show
notes for everything that we discussed
at tim dot blog forward slash maurice
and i wanted to read a quote
before we go which i was thinking of as
you were speaking not too long ago
maurice and this is a quote that i used
to open
all of my public talks with for about a
decade
and it is a quote from mark twain and it
applies right now
and always on so many levels and the
quote is
whenever you find yourself on the side
of the majority it's time to pause and
reflect
i think that applies certainly right now
and is highly highly relevant so
pause and reflect question your
assumptions look at not just your own
needs but
you know society's needs moving forward
because ultimately it's all intertwined
and until next time thanks to everybody
for listening
hey guys this is tim again just a few
more things before you take off
number one this is five bullet friday
do you want to get a short email from me
would you enjoy getting a short email
from me every friday
that provides a little morsel of fun
before the weekend and five bullet
friday is a very short email
where i share the coolest things i've
found or that i've been pondering over
the week
that could include favorite new albums
that i've discovered it could include
gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of
weird [ __ ] that i've somehow dug up in
the
the world of the esoteric as i do it
could include
favorite articles that i've read and
that i've shared with
my close friends for instance and it's
very short it's just a little
tiny bite of goodness before you head
off for the weekend so if you want to
receive that
check it out just go to four
hourworkweek.com that's
4hourworkweek.com all spelled out and
just drop in
your email and you will get the very
next one and if you sign up
i hope you enjoy it this episode of the
tim ferriss show is brought to you by
athletic
greens i get asked all the time if i
could only take one supplement what
would it be
the answer is inevitably athletic greeds
i view it as and a lot of
you now view it as all-in-one
nutritional insurance
i recommended it way back in 2010 in the
four-hour body
and i did not get paid to do so i've
been using it since before that
and i use it in a lot of different ways
i travel with it to avoid getting sick
or to help mitigate the likelihood of
getting sick i take it in the morning to
ensure optimal performance and overall
it covers my bases if i can't get what i
need from whole food meals throughout
the rest of the day
and if you want to give athletic greens
a try they're offering a free 20 count
travel pack
for first time users i nearly always
travel with at least
three or four of these one dose bags in
other words if you buy athletic greens
as a first time buyer
you now get for a limited time an extra
79
in free product so check out the details
at athleticgreens.com forward slash
tim again that's athleticgreens.com
forward slash tim
for your free travel pack with any
purchase
this episode is brought to you by
expressvpn
i've been using expressvpn since last
summer and i started using it as a
full retail paying customer i always
test things before considering sponsors
and i find it to be a super reliable way
to make sure that my data
are secure and encrypted you like how i
said data are like a pompous ass
but i like to ensure that my data are
secure and encrypted
but to do so without slowing down my
internet speed
if you ever use public wi-fi at say a
hotel or coffee shop where i often work
and as many of my listeners do you're
often sending data over an open network
meaning no encryption whatsoever one way
to ensure
that all of your data are encrypted and
cannot be easily read by
hackers or script kitties or whoever is
by
using expressvpn and the onboarding
process for expressvpn
meaning the sign up flow the use of the
product is one of the best i've ever
seen in my life
all you need to do is download the
expressvpn app on your computer
or smartphone and then use the internet
just as you normally would
you click one button in the expressvpn
app to secure 100 of your network
data it's kind of ridiculously simple
and as many of you know i only recommend
brands that i have researched
and vetted thoroughly for me of the many
vpn solutions out there expressvpn is
one of the best on the market and i use
it personally
here are a few reasons why first privacy
expressvpn does not log your data
lots of cheap or free vpns make money by
selling your data believe it or not
to add companies and so on expressvpn
developed technology
called trusted server to prevent their
servers from
logging your information second speed
many vpns slow your connection
down or make your device seem sluggish
just
to a crawl i've been using expressvpn
for a while now as i mentioned
and my internet speeds are blazingly
fast i don't even notice it honestly i
forget that it's even on
so that includes when i connect to
servers thousands of miles away or
during travel i can still stream hd
quality videos with zero lag
the last thing that really sets
expressvpn apart is how easy it is to
use
as i mentioned earlier unlike other vpns
you don't have to input or program
anything
you just start up the app click one
button and that's it
super super simple and by the way it's
not just me saying all this about but
expressvpn
you've got tech radar the verge cnet and
many other
publications rating expressvpn as the
number one vpn
in zeverd so consider protecting
yourself
with the vpn that i use and trust use my
link expressvpn.com
tim today and get an extra three months
free on a one year package
that's expressvpn
tim visit expressvpn.com tim
to learn more
you